The following content is
provided by MIT OpenCourseWare
under a Creative Commons
license.
Additional information about
our license and MIT
OpenCourseWare in general is
available at ocw.mit.edu.
We finished the unit on
oxidation-reduction on
Wednesday.
And so now we are moving into
the next unit,
which is transition metals,
and that is Chapter 16 in your
book.
And following transition
metals, the last unit is on
kinetics or rates of reaction,
and that is a little bit of a
longer unit.
So there are only two more
units coming up in the course.
Today I am going to introduce
you to the transition metal
unit, and this follows nicely
from oxidation-reduction since
you saw a lot of electrons being
lost and gained.
And metals are definitely
something that will gain and
lose electrons,
so it follows nicely from that.
Today is an introduction,
and on Monday we are going to
talk about crystal field theory,
which is a topic that most
people have not seen in high
school.
At least that has been true in
past years.
It looks a little bit scary
sometimes to people because it
looks different.
It is not something that seems
familiar.
It is actually not that hard,
but I strongly recommend coming
and being present in lecture and
working the problems.
That is how you learn how to do
this part.
And this often plays,
this particular unit on
transition metals,
is a dominant theme on the
final exam, so you will see it
there.
If people could settle down a
little, I am even having trouble
hearing myself.
That is going to be Monday.
And then on Wednesday we are
going to talk about shapes of
coordination complexes,
and this fits in nicely with
the transition metals.
We are going to talk about
vesper theory.
And then the following Monday
we continue on and talk about
how one can use crystal field
theory to think about what
colors molecules with transition
metals have.
These units,
it is a little bit of a strange
order this year because of the
Thanksgiving holidays,
but that is what is coming up.
Again, this is a unit that most
people have not seen before in
high school.
And, as I mentioned before,
problem set nine,
which is handed out today,
you will see that it is really
quite short.
It just covers today's lecture
and Monday's lecture.
It just has a few problems on
it, so it should just kind of
keep you from falling behind
with the material --
-- But not take too much time,
so you will be able to get that
done before Thanksgiving.
All right.
Today there are a lot of
topics.
That is what happens when you
introduce a new area.
You need to go through a bunch
of different kinds of
definitions.
And so today we are going to
talk about coordination
complexes.
And we are going to talk about
coordination complex notation,
coordination number,
structures, just briefly of
coordination complexes.
Again, on Wednesday,
we are going to be coming back
next Wednesday and talking much
more about these structures,
but we will give a little
introduction today.
We are going to introduce
something called the chelate
effect and talk about isomers.
And also, since we are talking
about transition metals,
we are going to start talking
about d-electrons and
d-orbitals.
This is, again,
all in Chapter 16 in your book.
Here is that relevant part of
the periodic table that we will
be talking about in this unit.
These are what are called
transition metals.
And this is a part of the
periodic table that is near and
dear to the hearts of many
faculty members in the Chemistry
Department, including my own.
We study proteins that use
these metals to catalyze
reactions.
And so this color scheme is
actually out of a book that was
published by Steve Lippard,
who is a faculty member in the
Chemistry Department.
I will mention him again later
in the day.
He does a lot of work on the
area called Metals in Biology,
these transition metals that
play a role in biological
systems.
And this book was also with
Jeremy Berg, who is the current
head of the general medicine
component of the National
Institutes of Health.
And so he is somebody else who
has thought a lot about metals
in biology.
In his case,
in particular,
zinc.
Why are metals important in
biological systems?
Well, proteins,
and I have talked some about
proteins already,
are composed of amino acids.
You have carbon,
nitrogen, oxygen,
sulfur.
And there is quite a bit of
chemistry that these particular
elements can do,
that amino acids can do,
but there are some pretty
challenging chemical reactions.
We talked in the unit on
chemical equilibrium about a
challenging reaction,
splitting dinitrogen.
And I told you about the
Haber-Bosch and how we need to
do this to get fertilizers.
And so it is an important
industrial process that an
enzyme can also do very
efficiently without the high
pressures and temperatures that
human beings seem to need to get
this reaction to go.
That is one example of a
protein that uses metals to do
the chemistry.
And the active site of that
enzyme is full of different
kinds of metals.
Up here says global cycling of
nitrogen, hydrogen and carbon.
And so often some of the most
fundamental reactions are also
very challenging reactions and
require metals to make them go.
Radical chemistry reactions,
making various products like
vitamins or deoxynucleotides,
the building block of DNA.
And we have some DNA here with
us today in class.
A lot of these reactions
require metals.
In this orange color here,
those are metals that are found
in biological systems,
but there are also some metals
in gray.
And some have both orange and
gray.
There are other metals that are
used as drugs or to probe
biological systems.
There is a whole area of sort
of metals in medicine where
people are using,
say, looking at the use of gold
for treating arthritis.
There is a lot of relevance of
these transition metals or
d-block metals to medicine.
Let's talk about the abilities
of these metals to form
complexes, and this is important
for their ability to function in
all systems, including the human
body.
A key feature is that they can
form complexes,
and let's look at why.
And so these complexes then,
of the metal and their ligands,
are known as these coordination
complexes.
You have a positive metal ion,
and it can attract electron
density.
And that is usually in the form
of a lone pair of electrons from
another atom.
And so when you bring together
this metal and these other atoms
and their lone pairs,
then you form this kind of
complex.
And so if we look at the
different roles that things
play, you have donor atoms.
And they are called ligands.
You often talk about a ligand
being coordinated to a metal.
And we mentioned Lewis acids
and Lewis bases when we were
talking about acid-base,
and we didn't really do much
with them when we were talking
about acid-base.
And I said this would come back
later.
Lewis acids and Lewis bases are
very relevant in terms of
talking about how coordination
complexes are formed.
A Lewis base is going to donate
lone pair electrons.
And here are some examples.
Again, these are referred to as
ligands.
And so they would be acting as
Lewis bases typically by
donating their lone pair.
Here are some of the ones that
you are going to see in this
unit.
And some of these will become
familiar to you as we go through
the next few lectures.
They all have these lone pairs.
And the metal is very happy to
see these ligands coming,
and they will coordinate and
form these coordination
complexes.
Then you need an acceptor atom,
and that is the transition
metal.
That is going to act as the
Lewis acid, and it is going to
accept that lone pair that is
being donated by the ligand.
Let's look at some example of
some of these metals.
And we saw some of these on the
periodic table.
These are all these d-block or
transition metals.
Then the coordination complex
is the metal surrounded by the
ligands, or the Lewis acids
surrounded by the Lewis bases.
Here is a picture.
We have cobalt in the center
here, and then there are six NH
three groups which are
acting as the ligands,
and their lone pairs are
pointing toward the metal.
And so, again,
the coordination complex,
all is meant by that is the
metal surrounded by the ligands.
And, in this case,
there is a little bracket on
the side with a plus three
charge.
And, for this particular
complex, you might have like
three chloride ions hanging
around.
Three negatively charged ions
to kind of counterbalance the
fact that this coordination
complex has a plus three overall
charge.
And so the charge would be
distributed, but it is indicated
that this whole complex has this
charge by that little bracket
and the plus three.
Again, here,
cobalt is acting as the Lewis
acid.
It is accepting the electrons
that are being donated by the
ligands.
It is the acceptor atom.
And the NH three groups
are acting as the Lewis bases.
They are the donor atoms,
so they are donating a lone
pair of electrons.
Now we can introduce a term
called coordination number,
C.N., and that is pretty
simple.
It is just a number of ligands
that are bonded to the metal.
And so here there are six.
The coordination number is six.
That would be written as C.N.
equals 6.
And you have six ligands
comprising the primary
coordination sphere.
We also have three chlorines
hanging around,
but they are not coordinated to
the metal, so they don't get
counted in this.
You are only interested in the
ligands that are actually
coordinated in the complex.
C.N.
numbers typically range from 2
to 12, but 6 is the most common.
You are going to be seeing a
lot of different coordination
complexes like this.
Let me just show you how that
would be written.
When you are doing a problem in
your book, it is mostly likely
not going to be drawn.
You are going to see notation
for this instead.
And so this particular one
would be indicated,
you have the cobalt,
and then you have your NH three
groups.
There are six of them,
so that is indicated there.
Then you have a bracket around
the outside with a plus three,
so that indicates that the
charge of everything inside
equals plus three.
You also
might see this,
where outside the bracket you
have three chloride ions.
And so you should be able to
think backwards to this and say,
well, if we have three things
with a negative one charge.
And you see why the
oxidation-reduction unit was
important before this.
Because we talked about
oxidation numbers and all the
rules for assigning oxidation
numbers.
You are going to need that
knowledge to do this unit as
well.
You should know that this is
going to be minus one for each
chloride, so that would be
three, which would mean that if
this is minus three,
this bracket would be plus
three, for this one down here is
written to be neutral.
You will be seeing this and
need to back calculate.
Then you are also going to need
to calculate what the oxidation
numbers of the things within the
bracket are as well.
And we will talk more about
that a little later in the
lecture.
Again, the NH three
within the brackets means it is
bound to the cobalt.
That would be this picture
here.
There are six of them so you
would draw them as six around.
And let me just mention a
little bit about this particular
configuration.
Here, where there is sort of a
thick line coming out,
indicates that it is coming
toward you.
Here, in this case,
you would have two atoms coming
toward you.
The dashed lines here are
showing that there are two atoms
back behind the plane.
And then when you have the
straight line,
that is in the plane.
This picture here is showing
you this type of geometry,
which is called what?
Octahedral geometry,
right.
Let's talk about octahedral
geometry and the other
geometries that you are going to
see most often in this
particular unit.
Again, I am going to do much
more on this on Wednesday,
but this is just a very brief
introduction to the structures
that you will see the most in
this particular unit.
For a coordination number of
six, you are just going to see
one type of geometry,
which is this octahedral
geometry, which I just showed
you.
For a coordination number of
five, you will see two different
types of geometry in this unit.
And let's take a look at this.
The first one over here,
the trigonal bipyramidal.
Here is an example of that.
And I will try to have this as
it is.
Three ligands are in the plane.
You have up and down,
and out here,
one ligand is pointing out
toward you with the thick line,
and another ligand is going
back with the dashed line here.
That is one there.
We talked about the geometry.
And I forgot to mention that
those are 90 degree angles,
which I think is pretty easy to
see when you look at it,
that you would have 90 degrees
in between those bonds.
And what about for this one?
What do we have going for the
red?
What kind of angle is that?
120.
And what about from the red to
the black?
90.
Those are the angles we would
see in here.
And this is going to become
important because we are going
to be talking about d-orbitals.
And where the d-orbitals are
for the metal,
which is in the center of the
coordination complex.
One of the issues we will be
discussing is,
where are the atoms with
respect to those d-orbitals?
Geometry becomes important at
this point.
The other type of coordination
complex you might see,
here the metal is gray in the
middle, and so then we have our
ligands bonded to it.
If you have five ligands you
also might see this geometry
here, so this square pyramidal
geometry.
And what are the angles between
all of the atoms here?
90.
Now, in the case where you have
four ligands bound to your
central metal,
there are two possibilities for
the geometry that you will see.
One is square planner.
In this case,
it is drawn with two ligands
coming out towards you and two
ligands going behind.
And what would be the geometry
between these guys?
90 as well.
And so this is one of the easy
ones to remember because it is a
square and it is planar.
That is an easy one to
remember.
The other that you might see
when you have four ligands is
this guy, tetrahedral.
And what are the angles here?
109.5.
And then if you have three
ligands, pretty much this is all
you are going to see in this
unit, and so we have the
trigonal planar.
Again, it looks trigonal and it
is also quite planar.
And what are our angles here?
120.
And linear is going to give you
what angle?
180.
You will see this one as well.
And this model is a little old,
so it is not really so linear
anymore, but it is still
supposed to be.
We are going to bring back,
I am going to bring these
models to class for a lot of the
next lectures because thinking
about the structure is going to
be very important in thinking
about the properties of
transition metals.
All right.
What else can transition metals
do?
What are some of the other
things?
When you talk about transition
metals and coordination
complexes, you need to talk
about the chelate effect.
We have seen so far ligands
binding at one site,
but some ligands can bind a
metal at more than one site.
And so then you start talking
about chelates.
First, a ligand that can bind a
metal at one site is called
unidentate or monodentate.
And the dent comes from dentist
or tooth.
This would be one.
If you have a ligand that can
bind at more than one point of
attachment, then it is called a
chelating ligand.
And the coordination complex
that it forms is called a
chelate.
And so this is Greek for claws.
It seems like claws are coming
down and binding to the metal.
Anything above one would be
considered a chelate if it has
two points of attachment or
three or four.
Bidendate means two points.
And this nomenclature,
not too challenging.
People are usually pretty good
at guessing what they mean.
Tridentate would have how many
points of attachment?
Three.
Tetradentate?
Four.
Hexadendate?
Six.
There are some people,
this was a question,
I think, hexadentate on a final
one year people got it wrong.
Don't get something like that
wrong.
Save the things you are going
to get wrong for the really hard
part.
This is really not so
difficult.
That should be some bonus
points there for you.
If you remember the dentate,
and this term actually gets
used quite a bit,
you will be all set.
What is the chelate effect?
Chelates are ligands that can
bind at more than one point of
attachment.
What is the chelate effect?
Well, it turns out that metal
chelates are very,
very stable.
And so this is a thermodynamic
property that they have.
And it is believed,
or the rationale for the
stability which is observed,
is that it is an entropic
factor that is going on.
The binding of that chelate at
more than one point of
attachment is entropically
favorable, because you are going
to be releasing waters as you do
this.
We are going to come back,
and I am going to explain this
using an example in a few
minutes.
First let me give you some
examples of chelates,
and then I will show you how
this chelate effect could work.
There are examples of chelates
in biological systems.
And it may not be a surprise to
some of you that one of the
chelates is vitamin B12.
And that would be one that I
would pick to mention in
particular.
Here the chelate,
this is all one ligand.
This whole bottom part is
attached.
It is one ligand.
We have this,
called the corn ring.
You have cobalt in the middle.
And it is coordinated by this
planar part.
And you have four nitrogen
ligands coordinating.
It is one ring system here,
called the corn ring,
that is attaching at four
points of attachment.
You also have an upper ligand
here, and this is an adenosyl
moiety.
And we have a lower ligand.
And we talked about this before
with buffers effects.
Because, if this lower ligand
is detached on the protein,
it has to fit into a binding
site.
And genetic defects that block
that impair the activity of the
enzyme.
That was mentioned before.
This actually has six different
ligands and we'll classify as a
chelate, or six different points
of attachment and classifies as
a chelate.
Let me just sort of spin that
around so you can kind of get a
sense of the geometry here.
Again, here is the cobalt in
the middle, the upper ligand and
the lower ligand.
And if we move that around,
see if you can get a sense of
the sort of geometry around that
cobalt.
You have four in a plane here,
one on top and one on bottom,
so it is sort of an octahedral
type coordination of that metal
in the center.
I thought I would just mention
the person who determined the
structure of vitamin B12.
That is Dorothy Hodgkin.
For her work on this,
and on penicillin,
she received a Nobel Prize,
because at the time she was
studying the structure,
it was really considered very
large for the technique that she
used, which is x-ray
crystallography.
And people didn't think she
would be able to determine where
all those atoms were located in
something that was that big
using crystallography.
Since then we have gone on to
solve much larger structures.
But she really opened the doors
for people thinking about this
technique as being important in
biological systems.
She had a number of graduate
students who went on to do some
pretty spectacular things and
really helped to establish the
field of crystallography.
And I will just mention one of
her graduate students who was
not as successful as a
crystallographer.
This is what I do.
And not everybody can do X-ray
crystallography.
It is a bit challenging.
And some people had to sort of
find something else to do with
their lives.
One of her students didn't
quite cut it as a
crystallographer,
but the good news is she was
still able to find a job.
And it is actually kind of
interesting that Dorothy Hodgkin
was a real socialist.
She was very involved in
left-wing issues,
but she stayed friend with
Margaret Thatcher throughout the
years.
And it would have been very
interesting to be in a living
room with the two of them
hearing them talk about
politics.
Maybe they would talk about
crystallography,
I don't really know,
if they were together.
That might have been safer.
That is one example of a
chelate.
Here is another example of a
chelate, and this is called
EDTA.
And so it has many points for
attachment to a metal.
We have a lone pair up here on
this atom, so we have a donor
here.
We have another lone pair,
another donor site here.
Another lone pair,
Also over here,
and here, and here.
This ligand can attach to
something in six places.
Here, again,
is the free molecule.
And here is what it looks like
when it is attached to the
metal.
See this oxygen here,
over here, and then if you
follow it down,
over here, this nitrogen is
also coordinated.
If we go over here,
then this oxygen is
coordinated.
If we come from this nitrogen
over to the other nitrogen,
it is over here.
Go down to this oxygen,
this oxygen is coordinated down
here, and then in purple we have
the last coordination.
What is the geometry around
that metal site?
You have these six ligands,
so what is that going to be?
It is going to be an
octahedral.
You should have angles around
90.
And it is also hexadentate,
so you have a ligand binding
with six points of attachment.
It would also have a C.N.
number, then,
of six.
Why the chelate effect?
Why are complexes like that so
stable?
The chelate effect could be
viewed in this slide.
Before you have the EDTA bound,
we have six water molecules
around it.
Then we bind one molecule of
EDTA.
It binds in the hexadentate
complex, releasing all six
waters.
Where is entropy greater?
When you have one free thing or
when you have six free things?
Six.
This is entropically favorable.
You are creating disorder.
You are binding one thing and
releasing six things.
That is why these complexes are
really quite stable.
We are getting back to entropy
now.
We have been talking about
delta G.
We had delta H.
Now we have delta S.
That is the chelate effect.
And we talk about it due to
this entropic effect accompanied
by the release of non-chelating
ligands, usually water,
from the coordination sphere.
In this case,
one ligand binding displacing
six things is favorable.
The chelate effect leads to a
lot of practical uses.
Here, some of the uses would be
in medicine.
If you discover over
Thanksgiving that your one and a
half year old niece or nephew
has discovered paint on the
windowsill is peeling and is
starting eating the paint off of
the windowsill,
you might want to remember when
that was painted last and if
there was lead in that paint and
rush the child to the emergency
room.
And when you get there,
just in case the people there,
you know, on Thanksgiving it is
always dangerous to be in an
emergency room.
You might say,
give this kid EDTA.
That is really what is used.
And that will chelate,
then, the lead out of the
system, before it can bind to
things and do a lot of damage.
This is one of the chelators
that is used.
It is a chelate effect.
It works pretty well if someone
has been exposed to something
like lead, which is pretty
toxic, and you want to get it
out of their system.
That is one use.
It is also in food.
It is a food additive.
Sometimes it is fun after you
take a couple chemistry courses
to actually start reading the
labels of the food that you are
consuming and some of those
words will actually start making
sense.
One thing that you will often
see is EDTA.
And it will say,
EDTA was added for freshness.
One thing that EDTA can do.
Microorganisms,
bacteria, other things that you
would rather not have consuming
your food at the time that you
also want to consume it need
metals for life,
as we all do.
If you add EDTA,
it is a good way of preventing
other kinds of unwanted
microorganisms from growing on
the food.
Because it will chelate all the
metals and the organisms cannot
live.
Added for freshness is a more
polite way of saying that this
food is less likely to be
contaminated with lots of
bacteria growing on top of it.
Another thing that it can be
used for is cleaning,
bathtub cleaning or other
kinds, but bathtubs and showers
in particular.
There is calcium in tub scum.
And most kinds of cleaners have
something that chelates out that
calcium which allows you to
clean.
Again, over Thanksgiving,
one thing that happens to a lot
of people when they go home is
that their parents say,
help us clean to get ready for
everyone coming.
And so you might be using EDTA
then as well.
I thought I would tell you a
little story about how knowledge
from freshman chemistry can make
somebody money.
This is a really kind of fun
story.
I don't know if it was around
Thanksgiving,
it might have been.
One day Robert Black had a
life-altering experience.
His wife said to him,
could you clean the tub?
Apparently Robert Black had
never cleaned the tub before
that time, and so he went to
clean it.
Apparently, maybe it had not
been cleaned in a while.
And he discovered that it is
really hard.
You have to scrub a lot to get
the tub clean.
He thought, wouldn't it be nice
if one never had to clean a tub?
He came up with this idea.
And here is one of the products
that came out of this,
Sparkling Shower,
available at La Verde's.
And what he did was he put the
same ingredients,
including EDTA,
in that you have in most
cleaners, but he had sort of a
novel pitch.
Every time you take a shower,
just squirt the shower or the
tub, and then you never really
have to clean it.
In this patent he had a
surfactant chelating agent,
EDTA, and an alcohol.
You had a surfactant to sort of
break up the water tension,
the chelating agent to
sequester out the salts in the
scum, and alcohol to dissolve
the more oily ingredients.
And so those together kind of
got everything loose and ready
to go.
And the surfactant kind of
helped it run off.
If you squirt your shower every
time you shower,
you will never really have to
clean it.
He used all ingredients that
were known before,
but packaged it slightly
differently.
Again, EDTA is one of the
ingredients in these products.
And so sales of these
particular products have reached
$70 million every year.
I think that the wife is
probably very happy that one day
she insisted that he clean the
tub.
Because this turned out to be a
pretty profitable exercise.
It is also an example of how
some very simple chemistry can
yield you quite a bit of money.
All right.
Tub cleaner.
There was one more that I
thought of.
Anybody a fan of vampire
movies?
Not really all that many.
It is a little surprising.
I am not sure you are all
telling the truth.
If any of you happened to see
Blade, you might be aware of
another use for EDTA.
If you remember,
you may not have noticed what
they were mentioning at the
time, but they came up with a
great way of killing vampires.
There were these darts filled
with EDTA.
I think the kind of general
premise that you can rationalize
this Hollywood special feature
is that vampires drink blood,
blood has iron,
and if they are pretty much all
blood, if you give them
something that chelates out the
iron, it could cause some kind
of harmful effect.
In the movie they exploded,
and sort of disintegrated
completely.
If you take your niece or
nephew to the emergency room for
eating lead paint this will not
happen.
I am quite sure.
But it was really very
spectacular.
Here they are,
the little darts filled with
EDTA.
Again, more knowledge that
could be useful on some
occasion, perhaps,
I am not really sure.
I have a feeling that most of
you will find the top three more
useful, but here is the complete
list that I have been able to
come up with for the uses of
chelators.
All right.
Those are some coordination
complexes, either single ligands
bound around a central metal,
or chelating ligands bound
around a central metal.
There are other coordination
complexes which have important
features.
And one thing that we will talk
about is isomers.
Geometric isomers can have very
different properties to them.
It seems like it is pretty much
almost the exact same compound.
But the arrangement of the
atoms is slightly different,
and that can yield two very
different properties for those
particular compounds.
Let's look at one example.
This is platinum,
and it has two NH three
ligands and two chloride
ligands.
And so that is in the bracket.
Those four different ligands
are coordinated centrally to the
platinum.
It would have a C.N.
number of four.
And the most common shape that
you would see for this would be
this one here,
this square planar shape.
Depending on how you arrange
the four different ligands,
two NH three and two
Cl, you get a very different
result.
We have, in this arrangement,
a compound called cisplatinum.
You can have a cis arrangement,
where the chlorides are on one
side and the ammonia groups are
on the other side,
or you can have transplatinum,
where the ligands are across
from each other.
Here are these two different
molecules.
Here they are cis with respect
to each other,
and here they are trans with
respect to each other.
One is a very potent drug that
is used in treatment of cancer.
The other has no known
function.
They are composed of identical
atoms.
Why is this different?
Why are there different
functions with the different
geometries?
Well, as it turns out,
it is real important to have
the atoms on the same side.
As shown in this slide,
I said I would mention Steve
Lippard again,
and here I am,
this has been a subject of
research in Steve Lippard's
laboratory here in the chemistry
department at MIT for a number
of years.
If you have a cancer cell and
you want to kill the cancer
cell, one thing that you can do
is give it cisplantinum.
The cisplatinum comes and binds
to DNA.
Here is a little cartoon of DNA
here.
There is the actual model of
DNA structure down here,
in the front of the room.
When it binds,
then it can inhibit
transcription.
And so this can then lead to
cell death.
And so Steve has been really
looking at this issue,
trying to redesign cisplatinum
to see if you get a better drug,
looking at other factors which
might have an additive effect.
This particular drug is used
often for prostate cancer and
has really been quite effective.
Why does it matter if they are
on the same side?
Well, if you look at this
complex and the other,
you see that only two of these
ligands are left.
Two of the ligands are gone.
At those sites it is actually
coordinated to the DNA itself.
That is why it is important
that they are on the same side.
You want to release two
chlorides and have it bind to
DNA this way.
If it is on the other side,
it really doesn't work as well.
If we go over and look at the
DNA molecule for a minute,
you see that if you want to
have two free sites to
coordinate two DNA molecules.
Of course, this is the totally
wrong scale.
You want these on the same
side.
If I made it on the right
scale, it would not fit in the
room, really.
This is more or less,
you can imagine.
If you are going down here and
you want to release just the
chloride ligands,
well, you cannot get the
chloride ligands to be on the
right side for this.
Molecules that have different
shapes may have different
properties.
And if you are in an
environment you are looking to
react with a particular
molecule.
I will show you another kind of
view of DNA.
DNA is a really beautiful
molecule.
Here you have something you can
carry around and show your
friends, but also there is a
smaller model of DNA.
This is actually an artist in
Michigan who will carve out
within these blocks any atomic
structure that you have.
And you can show the sort of
bases in the detail.
That is what DNA looks like
sort of from the top and then
from the side.
It is just a really beautiful
molecule.
This is a nice example.
Steve Lippard often takes a lot
of UROP students,
so it might be something,
if you are interested in this
area, that you might want to
look at his web page and see if
that type of research interests
you.
I lost my pointer.
The cisplantinum has the effect
because you need to release
chlorides on the same side,
so that it can bind DNA over
here.
This cannot bind DNA because
you don't have the chlorides
together, so they cannot be
released and you won't interact
with the DNA.
Again, these different isomers
have really, really different
properties.
Here, we look at optical
isomers or enantiomers --
-- And introduce the idea of a
mirror plane,
here.
When you have two different
isomers, and if they are not
superimposable,
that means there is a mirror
plane and that they are chiral.
And chiral molecules can have
vastly different properties,
again, if they are in a chiral
environment such as the human
body.
Let's just look at these two.
See that there is a mirror
plane.
Here, we have the green on top,
the NH three on top,
chloride in gray here on the
bottom, and then on the side we
have the oxygens,
the black atoms here,
more chlorides here;
on the other side there are
also oxygens pointing out in
front, another NH three
group sort of putting in back.
And so they are very,
very similar.
But if you try to superimpose
them, you will realize that it
doesn't match up.
If you try again other ways,
put another green over here,
no, that is wrong,
too.
And you can spend maybe not
very long convincing yourself
that, in fact,
these are non-superimposable.
They are mirror images,
so they are chiral compounds.
And the idea of chiral
compounds, we will come back,
and you will hear much more
about that if you take organic
chemistry, 5.12 or 5.13.
Now we have to get to some
business that we need to think
more about the properties of
these elements.
And that is,
we need to count.
A lot of counting in these
units, oxidation-reduction,
and also in this unit,
counting skills.
We need to figure out how many
d-electrons are involved in
coordination complexes to be
able to rationalize their
properties.
This is pretty straightforward.
One can figure this out,
what the d-electron count is,
if you know the group number
from the periodic table and the
oxidation number of the metal.
We know how to calculate
oxidation numbers at this point,
and the periodic table in your
book.
Let's just take a look at a
couple of examples and count
some d-electrons.
Suppose we have a coordination
complex.
It has cobalt in it,
it has six ammonia ligands,
and it has a charge of plus
three for the overall complex.
Then we
need to figure out what the
oxidation number of cobalt is
first.
What is the overall charge on
NH3?
That is zero.
This is a neutral molecule.
And if you don't know that,
this is something you will
memorize as you go through this
unit.
What does that leave you for,
for cobalt?
Plus three, because it all has
to add up, just as it has
before.
And so we figure out the
oxidation number first.
And then second,
we would figure out the
d-count.
We need to look at the periodic
table and see where it is.
Here we have cobalt in group 9.
We have group number 9 minus
the oxidation number,
which is three,
that we just calculated,
and we are left with six.
And you will often see this
written as d to the six
for the d-count number of
electrons.
One year when I had this,
I think the first year,
I actually had,
I think, 9 minus 3 equals 5 in
the handout.
And that was rather
embarrassing.
Oh, wait.
I want to do one more example
first, or two more examples
first.
Let's try just a couple of
more.
All right.
There are some that will become
very familiar to you as you do
these.
Let's look at nickel with CO
ligands, four of them,
written like this.
There is nothing
up here.
That means that the overall
charge has to equal zero.
CO, that is one that you will
come across, and its overall
charge is also going to be zero.
It is neutral as well.
And so what does that leave for
nickel?
Zero.
Sometimes not very exciting.
All right.
If your oxidation number is
zero, then we want to look up
and figure out what the d-count
is.
We have to see where nickel is.
It is in group 10,
so we have 10 minus 0.
It is a d ten system.
Let's just try one more.
Cobalt, again,
two molecules of water,
and one of NH three ,
and three of chloride,
to the minus one.
Let's put that up a little bit.
All right.
Overall, this has to be minus
one.
What is the charge on chloride
going to be?
It will be minus one.
There will be three of them.
NH3 was what again?
Zero.
Do you want to guess what water
is going to be?
Zero.
Two zeros.
What does that leave you for
cobalt?
Plus two.
All right.
Cobalt, we looked up before,
and it was in 9.
Over here we have plus two.
And we have group 9 minus 2 is
7, and so that is a d seven
system.
That is how you will do those
problems.
And you will need that on
Monday when we start talking
about crystal field theory.
In the last couple of minutes,
I want to remind you of the
shapes of d-orbitals.
This is leading into what we
knew next.
Again, we are thinking about
the shapes of the d-orbitals and
the metals, and then we are
thinking about the shapes of the
coordination complexes.
And we are trying to figure out
whether the ligands are going to
be near the d-orbitals or away.
And depending on how the
ligands are arranged with
respect to the d-orbitals
changes the properties of the
coordination complex.
All right.
There are five d-orbitals.
And you should be able to draw
them.
Again, the bar for successfully
drawing the d-orbitals is you
have to do as well as I do when
I try to draw the d-orbitals.
Again, it is a low bar for
drawing.
You just kind of need to get
some of the general features
right.
If we look at d z squared,
it has a maximum
amplitude along the z-axis.
And in this course we will
always try to keep the axes more
or less the same to help you
out.
And they will be labeled,
so you know where the z-axis
is.
Here is the z-axis,
and y is along the plane here.
And x is coming out toward you.
There is x.
And then you have a doughnut in
the x,y-plane.
d x squared minus y squared
has maximum
amplitudes along x and y.
It doesn't have anything along
z.
The orbitals are along y in the
plane of the board and along x
coming out toward you,
and also going behind the
screen.
Then we have three more.
We have d(yz),
and it has its amplitudes 45
degrees off the y and the
z-axis.
Here is z up and down and y
across the plane of the board.
And so these orbitals are drawn
to be 45 degrees off those axes.
d(xy) is 45 degrees to the x
and the z, so these are coming
out towards you and going
behind, and also going up.
And then d(xy) is 45 degrees
off of y and x.
And you will need to know how
to draw these and need to know
the shapes and to be able to
think about them in 3D,
so that you can imagine where
ligands are and how those
ligands are affected by these
d-orbitals.
Have a great weekend.